I do believe that there is going to be a
larger Financial Reckoning I I think
Elon is trying to
do as many things fiscally responsible
at Twitter right now because I think he
sees the storm is coming especially
financially that is going to be
correlated with centralized forces
pushing a Ubi pushing Central Bank
digital currencies pushing for a
solution that of course is going to
greatly benefit them and give them more
power over everyone else so I think
these layoffs are just more layoffs to
come already there was so much uh
layoffs in the tech industry when it
came to Amazon when it came to Facebook
when it came to Twitter these are not
accidental layoffs these are layoffs in
anticipation of the larger Financial
Market being turned upside down because
the last three years we prioritized
safety shutting down small mom and pop
businesses over of course Walmart Costco
and all these other billionaires that
got richer more than they ever did
before in their entire human history